en vídeos anteriores hemos hablado del
concepto elasticidad precio que puede
ser la elasticidad precio de la demanda
o sobre la elasticidad precio de la
oferta pero en ambas situaciones nos
referíamos al cambio porcentual en la
cantidad ante el cambio porcentual en el
precio si hablamos de la elasticidad
precio de la demanda tendríamos el
cambio porcentual en la cantidad
demandada ante el cambio porcentual en
el precio y cuando hablamos de la
elasticidad precio de la oferta nos
referimos al cambio porcentual en la
cantidad ofrecida ante el cambio
porcentual en el precio como lo hemos
mencionado con anterioridad en muchos
vídeos esta es una forma de medir qué
tan sensible es la cantidad demandada
ofrecida con respecto al cambio en el
precio lo que vamos a ver en este vídeo
es que este no es el único tipo de
elasticidad que les interesa a los
economistas existen muchos tipos
diferentes de elasticidad en donde nos
interesa saber qué tan sensible es una
cosa con respecto a otra por ejemplo
podemos ver el cambio porcentual en la
cantidad de trabajo ofrecida dividida
entre el cambio porcentual en los
salarios podemos ver esto como cambios
en el precio
el trabajo y podemos decir que esta es
la elasticidad precio de la oferta
particularmente en el mercado laboral
pero también podemos ver esto de otra
forma y más adelante haré otro vídeo
sobre este tema en donde podemos ver
esto como el cambio porcentual en la
cantidad demandada de un bien que
llamaremos bien uno dividido entre el
cambio porcentual en el precio no de ese
bien pues en este caso tendríamos una
elasticidad precio sino en el precio de
un bien 2 esta es una forma de ver qué
tan buen sustituto es el bien 1 con
respecto al bien 2 esto lo veremos con
mayor detalle pero el objetivo de este
vídeo es como pueden imaginarse es el
título que tenemos aquí es la
elasticidad ingreso en particular nos
enfocaremos en la elasticidad ingreso de
la demanda pueden imaginarse que será
esto es el cambio porcentual en la
cantidad demandada dividida entre en
lugar de pensar en el cambio porcentual
en el precio de ese bien o servicio
vamos a pensar en el cambio porcentual
en el ingreso de las personas que
podrían estar en él
parece bien normalmente esperaríamos que
cuando el cambio porcentual en el
ingreso aumenta también aumente el
cambio porcentual en la cantidad
demandada por ejemplo imaginemos el
mercado de los paquetes de vacaciones si
una persona tiene un mayor ingreso
entonces puede pagar una mayor cantidad
o mejor calidad en sus viajes
vacacionales esto sería un bien normal y
es lo que podríamos esperar pero podemos
tener lo contrario podemos imaginar una
situación en la que a pesar de que hay
un aumento en el cambio porcentual en el
ingreso esto no implica un aumento en el
cambio porcentual en la cantidad
demandada de hecho puede ocasionar una
disminución en el cambio porcentual en
la cantidad demandada es decir que la
cantidad demandada puede disminuir
pueden imaginar una situación de este
tipo piensen en el mercado de servicio
mecánico automotriz conforme las
personas tienen un mayor ingreso también
tienen acceso a mejores autos que sean
más confiables y que no se descompongan
tan seguido por lo que no necesitan ir
tan seguido al mecánico en esta
situación donde la demanda disminuye
cuando aumenta el ingreso
cambio porcentual es negativo y se tiene
un cambio porcentual positivo en el
ingreso a este tipo de bienes se le
conoce como un bien inferior aquí hay
que recordar que no sólo tenemos que
pensar en la elasticidad precio
relacionada con la demanda o con la
oferta sino que también existen otros
tipos de elasticidad pero para
comprender mejor la elasticidad de
ingreso vamos a ver un par de ejemplos
nos dicen supón que cuando el ingreso de
las personas aumenta 20% entonces ellas
compran 10% menos comida rápida en esta
situación qué tipo de bien será la
comida rápida pausa en el vídeo y
piensen en ello vemos que el ingreso
aumenta pero la demanda disminuye esta
situación la acabamos de mencionar se
trata de un bien inferior y además
pensemos en cuál es la elasticidad
ingreso de la demanda en esta situación
vamos a calcularla
recordemos que la elasticidad de ingreso
de la demanda va a ser igual al cambio
porcentual en la cantidad demandada
dividida entre el cambio porcentual en
el ingreso no en el precio a que va a
ser igual sabemos que el cambio
porcentual en el ingreso
en 20% y el cambio porcentual de la
cantidad demandada disminuyó 10% la
elasticidad ingreso de la demanda es
menos un medio y menos 0.5 veamos otro
ejemplo supón que sabemos que cuando el
ingreso de las personas en un país
aumenta 5% la demanda de servicios de
salud aumenta 10% qué tipo de bien
consideran las personas son los
servicios de salud normal o inferior
primero calculen la elasticidad ingreso
de la demanda para este ejemplo y
después respondan estas preguntas
primero calculamos la elasticidad de
ingreso de la demanda veamos el ingreso
aumenta 5% y la demanda de servicios de
salud aumentó 10% esto nos da una
elasticidad de ingreso de la demanda
igual a 2 y en general si esto es
positivo quiere decir que es un bien
normal si aumenta el ingreso y también
aumenta la cantidad demandada este es un
bien normal nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo